can you just give me 30 seconds to get
this off my chest once and for all I got
this email yesterday
I want you to look at it again because
you didn't catch it the first time
d-roc help them out and highlight the
part that I'm going to focus on this
time
can win once and for all in society in
May - June 2015
once and for all made people realize
sending bulk emails bulk blast emails
especially in this situation where it
says your name here your name here not
to Gary and by the way all the
misspellings Gary Varner's who kabocha
bulk emails that are not actually
addressed to me get the lead in in a
speed that is actually the way I'm
diluted the screen in which I delete an
email that is clearly not for me is
actually stunning once and for all in
this video please be a call to action to
the marketing community that bulk
blasting email for people that didn't
sign up for [ __ ] is the wrong move and I
ask anybody who's watched this video to
start replying to people with it so they
can hear me say [ __ ] you